you've always seemed like I'm gonna say
it you've always seemed like kind of a
cool guy to me a guy who knows how to
dress yeah you know you know like the
right I'm serious like you're always
worrying like the kind of glasses that I
suspect or the cool glasses to wear or
they're you've always got that jacket on
that I'm guessing is the cool jacket
that's just how you seemed to me yeah I
think that's something that's in my head
and then whenever I go out and do things
I realized that I'm absolutely not cool
so for a moment I think I'm cool like I
was in this is I was in London right and
this is a true story but it's not kind
of like a bragging rhaggy thing to say I
think so no a lot of people have access
to airline yeah yeah yeah I was in
London sorry and there's a lot of shitty
parts a lot and I was like I was going
record shopping and I saw this guy who
to me looked old I was like that guy so
he's older than me and he was wearing a
black t-shirt I'm like what is it with
old guys I'm wearing black t-shirts
buying records but that was exactly me
like I wear a black t-shirt and I think
the guy probably was actually my age and
it's just like this are you looking in a
mirror look he's doing what I'm doing I
I went to this show in downtown LA and
to me it was like so underground is a
band called circa is a singer named
circuit des yeux and I was like no one
knows who this is I'm gonna go down
there downtown no one goes down there to
see shows right I'll be the climb the
only guy there yeah that's what I
thought packed with guys my age they
kind of looked like me yeah i'm i yeah
i'm way in the back of the line i think
yeah